there are certain analytics the game
developers should always be thinking
about and it always starts at the high
level of lifetime value once you're we
have a good idea of how you want to
measure or calculate your lifetime value
then you can determine what other
analytics in particular that you want to
be looking at for instance usually
everybody starts with retention so
that's the number of people who are
coming back or the percentage of people
who are coming back on specific days day
1 day 14 day 28 on the monetization side
it really depends on the type of
monetization method that you're using so
if you're using primarily in-app
purchases then you want to look at the
average revenue per purchase the average
purchase size if you're looking at
things such as monetizing through ads
then you want to look at add specific
monetization metrics so things like the
effective cost per thousand the eCPM the
fill rate as well as you know
frequencies that you're showing adds
things like that all of this is
generally distilled into the ARPU the
average revenue per user or the RP pou
which is the average revenue per paying
user and along the way you can make up
whatever acronyms make the most sense
for your game